بالعوده للهجوم الذي اعلن عنه الكرملينا
اليوم الذي يعيد الى الواجهه دور المسيرات
في تغيير موازين المعارك ومفهوم الحروب
هذا التغيير الذي يصنفك احد ابرز التحولات
الجيوسيه منذ عام 2010 مبني على عده عوامل
اولها سهوله تحرك هذه المسيرات وعدم حاجه
المتحكم فيها للتدريب الطويل كالطائرات
التقليديه وهذا بطبيعه الحال ينسحب على
جاهزيتها للهبوط في اي موقع دون الحاجه
الى مدرج هبوط او تفاصيل تقنيه كثيره
لديها ايضا قدره على التجسس حيث تستطيع ان
تمسح وتصور الاماكن اماكن العدو وتقديمها
معلومات حيه مباشره عنها مع صعوبه رصدها
في كثير من الاحياء
تنخفض تكلفتها في مسيرات الكاميكازيه
الاتحاريه مثلا المحمله بشحنه تفجيريه
تبلغ قيمتها نحو 20 الف دولار فقط ما يضع
عبء على الدور التي تريد الدفاع عن نفسها
اذ تبلغ كلفه التصدي لهذه المضادات
الارضيه اضعاف تكلفه الهجوم
المسيرات ايضا خلال العقد الماضي كانت
محوريه في العديد من النزاعات كسوريه
اليمن اذربيجان ارمينيا اوكرانيا وليبيا
تحديدا في اذربيجان في المثال اقليم
ايضا هذه العوامل دفعت دول العالم الى رفع
الانفاق على هذه
المسيرات في بنود انفاقها العسكري لتجاوز
30 مليار دولار عام 2022
لكن هذه المسيرات تنقسم الى فئات حسب
وزنها وسرعتها ومهمتها ومن ابرزها فئه فئه
بوزن 150 كيلو جراما او اقل تستخدم لمهام
الاستطلاع او المراقبه او ايصال الذخائر
طبعا من اشهرها
الطائرات
الامريكيه 3 اي اي
هنالك ايضا فئه ثانيه هي فئه الهجوميه
الانتحاريه تعتبر المسيره الايرانيه شاهد
من الامثله عليها اذ حضرت اسمها كثيرا في
حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ويصل وزنها الى
200 كيلو جرام وتبلغ كلفه انتاجها حوالي
20 الف دولار فقط الفئه الثالثه تستخدم في
الهجمات ويمكنها التحليق لمده 24 ساعه ومن
اشهرها المسيره التركيه بيرق دار تي في 2
وتكلفه الواحده منها ما بين مليون وخمسه
ملايين وقامت برقدار بادوار بارزه في
المعارك في كل من اوكرانيا واثيوبيا
وارمينيا
الفئه الاخيره التي نستحضرها اليوم
فتتجاوز حمولتها 600 كلغ هي الاخطر بسبب
المهام الموكله اليها من اشهرها طبعا
المسيره الامريكيه ام كيو 1 وقد تم
استخدامها من قبل واشنطن في قصف العراق
وافغانستان